ah
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france 24 las campañas
de vacunación en el mundo contra la cob
y 19 se han acelerado al mismo tiempo
decenas de países la organización
mundial de la salud y varias
organizaciones no gubernamentales piden
a los países ricos ya los laboratorios
acepten suspender de manera provisional
los derechos de propiedad intelectual a
fin de acelerar la aplicación de la
vacuna de manera más equitativa para
hablar de este tema saludamos a
distancia en razón de las medidas de
seguridad sanitaria a jimena reyes
director para las américas de la
federación internacional por los
derechos humanos
efe dh jimena reyes bienvenida a esta
escala en parís muchas gracias muchas
gracias y un saludo a todos de vivientes
jimena reyes recientemente la federación
internacional por los derechos humanos
publicó una declaración en la que piden
precisamente a los países ricos ya los
laboratorios acepten suspender de manera
transitoria esos derechos de propiedad
intelectual de las vacunas
concretamente qué quiere decir esto de
los derechos de propiedad intelectual
sin los derechos de propiedad
intelectual que significan que las
empresas que registran patentes sobre
productos
no van a ser copiadas por otras empresas
y que guardan el monopolio y ésta afecta
desde los años 90 y ahora tienen un
status nivel internacional a través de
las regulaciones a las palencia de
quiero prácticamente todos los países
del mundo en la organización mundial del
comercio entonces estas son esas reglas
y esas reglas se aplican también para
por ejemplo las células vacunas que se
acaban de identificar
y venga a qué países o laboratorios
dirigen ustedes esta declaración
generalmente uno tiende a pensar en los
países de occidente pero es cierto que
también países como china o rusia
también producen esos medicamentos
y efectivamente esta declaración se
dirige a todos los países de la
organización mundial de comercio porque
se está discutiendo en estas semanas y
con una foto decisión en junio que
tienes que hacerte de una intimidad
esta propuesta que puso en la mesa
áfrica del sur india perdón a la cual ya
no está el país se se anda de vido donde
piden la suspensión de los patentes
relacionados por la tecnología con las
vacunas que
permitiría mejorar la situación de
comida pero en particular en los países
que están bloqueando el voto
lo cual puede ser una paradoja si son
los países de la unión europea vamos a
volver sobre eso precisamente
y también australia japón vamos a volver
sobre eso jimena al respecto los países
más avanzados así como los laboratorios
el argumento que dan para no aceptar la
suspensión de esos derechos de propiedad
intelectual gira en torno a dos ejes por
un lado dicen que si se suspenden
desestimularía la investigación
científica en favor del desarrollo de
las vacunas y además añaden los países
llamados del sur no tienen la capacidad
técnica para producir dichas vacunas que
responden ustedes a estos dos argumentos
jimena reyes
estamos primero que en este caso
particular por la gravedad de la
situación
los países invirtieron masivamente 7 mil
millones de euros fueron dados a las
empresas para desarrollar estas vacunas
entonces es el fundamento que dice que
la propiedad intelectual permite que el
pp o la empresa grande suficientemente
dinero para poder cubrir los gastos de
inversión aquí
no tiene espacio pero además de eso es
una cuestión de de valorar lo que
estamos de lo que estamos hablando
estamos hablando de ganar dinero y
estamos hablando de salvar vidas y a la
declaración que hacemos también hay que
agregar qué
numerosas instituciones de naciones
unidas están llamando a esta suspensión
por ejemplo el consejo de los derechos
humanos
estás en el comité de derechos
económicos sociales y culturales y en
las américas la misma comisión
interamericana betis humanos ha
publicado una resolución donde dice
necesitamos estar suspensión es una
cuestión de derecho a la vida y de
derecho a la salud que deben primar y
tener prioridad sobre estos derechos de
propiedad intelectual y la suspensión
que se solicita está limitada
temporalmente y también en ámbito
estamos pidiendo una revolución no
simplemente que se tome una decisión de
carácter transitorio exactamente lo
señala usted india y sudáfrica
promovieron en diciembre pasado una
reunión al interior de la organización
mundial del comercio pidiendo la
suspensión de los derechos de propiedad
intelectual ciertamente fue seguida a
esta propuesta por más de 100 países que
apoyaban la suspensión
comentaba fueron los estados unidos la
unión europea japón australia el reino
unido y brasil quienes han bloqueado
la iniciativa lo dice usted próximamente
habrá una nueva reunión de la
organización mundial del comercio para
evaluar esta situación la cosa es que se
requiere la unanimidad de los países del
amc para hacer pasar esta resolución
piensan ustedes que se podría
eventualmente llegar a este objetivo
dada la gravedad que estamos registrando
con el avance de la pandemia
pues nosotros es en nuestro adn somos
positivos utopistas tal vez entonces si
pensamos que se puede lograr y realmente
si los países estos países que están
bloqueando mirarán los intereses de sus
propios ciudadanos y también los
intereses el interés general mundial
aceptarían que estas vacunas son bienes
comunes y que las derechos de propiedad
intelectual no se deben aplicar porque
inclusive los países del norte estos que
están bloqueando están sufriendo
terriblemente tanto las poblaciones con
las medidas de confinamiento la economía
y también el nuevo rebrote el peligro de
que las nuevas cepas entonces esta
necesidad el 70 por ciento de la
población mundial llegue a la inmunidad
es en el interés del mundo entero y no
pueden ser la avaricia de unas carpas
seu ticas las que pongan en peligro a
esa necesidad de que salgamos de esta
crisis cómo calificarían ustedes esta
actitud notablemente en los países de la
unión europea es hipocresía ese egoísmo
hay un doble discurso países como
francia
han insistido en el hecho de que es
necesario precisamente se vacune al
mayor número de personas han dicho que
apoyan precisamente que se dan
facilidades a los países menos
desarrollados al mismo tiempo países
como españa dicen no es necesario
suspender los derechos de propiedad
intelectual como califican esa actitud
si ese es una actitud ambigua
y muy muy criticable y tal vez de una
actitud del pasado en el sentido de que
como decías estos mismos países están
diciendo es que los países del sur de
trasmano nate a la capacidad de producir
esas vacunas claro que si hay capacidad
industrial hay muchos remedios genéricos
se producen en el sur
entonces si existe esa capacidad y es
también esa mirada existencialista no
nosotros vamos a través del covan que
explica mismo que se ha puesto en pie a
regalar parte a vacunas
hablemos precisamente del cobaq y otras
vacunas
pero no hablemos precisamente del cobach
de acuerdo con la organización mundial
de la salud hasta la primera semana del
mes de abril
el cobas es este sistema precisamente
que procura distribuir de manera
equitativa entre los países menos
desarrollados la vacuna habría
distribuido alrededor de 40 millones de
dosis en 100 países de acuerdo con la
efe
h está funcionando bien el comics no no
es suficiente no es suficiente en
américa latina estamos
aparte de chile en una media de 2.5 por
ciento de la población vacunada y no
vamos a llegar nunca el objetivo inicial
del cop o bucks edad tener 2 mil
millones de 2
si se ve el avance muy lento pero es que
se ven 70 también a qué se debe
como sabes hay problemas de producción
hay una pelea entre los países desde el
norte donde es donde se produce las
vacunas para conservar el máximo de
efectivamente a países como el reino
unido efectivamente países como el reino
unido canadá tienen dosis para vacunar
cuatro veces a su población pero a usted
hacía referencia a los países de américa
latina ciertamente chile es el que el
más avanzado ha vacunado aproximadamente
a una quinta parte de su población el
resto de los países de américa latina
registran fuertes retrasos pero no hay
también un problema de corrupción de
falta de administración de mala gestión
de esta situación se acusa a los
laboratorios pero también los países de
la región tienen bastante
responsabilidad en ese sentido colombia
méjico etcétera
y efectivamente dos problemas primero el
desmantelamiento de
los sistemas de salud salud en muchos de
nuestros países y también de la
capacidad de poner en pie por políticas
de vacunas fuertes pero
si a eso se agrega los numerosos
escándalos de corrupción que se han dado
y que pueden ser lo que llaman a los
personajes 7 que no hay una claridad
sobre lo los órdenes de llegadas pero
también han habido la lo que es las
obras que están llamando que no hay no
hay nada
la vacuna entonces está el mal manejo de
los estados también ha agregado una capa
de grava la crisis virtualmente y ahí
también hay que agregar disfruta me
braulio pero también de que tenemos
países como brasil están en una
denegación total y a nivel estatal de la
importancia de tener una política de
confinamiento
de distancia acción social etcétera
mezclado alguna inestabilidad y
corrupción obviamente eso no puede
funcionar ciertamente nos quedan un poco
menos de un minuto jimena países como un
indio cuba están produciendo ya o cerca
de producir vacunas contra el apoyo a
ellos también se les va a pedir que se
dan los derechos de propiedad
intelectual de una manera muy breve por
favor claro a todos los países que
produzcan no a todas las empresas que
produzcas también se necesita esa
suspensión porque estamos en el ante un
desafío que tiene que merece medidas
tales como esa y que afecta a todo el
mundo pues estamos llegando ya al final
de esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a jimena reyes directora para
las américas de la federación
internacional por los derechos humanos
efe dh habernos acompañado desde
bruselas gracias jimena muy buen día ya
ustedes les damos una nueva cita en otra
escala en parís la próxima semana
[Música]